[Musik]
irgendwann hat er mir dann gesagt ja er
hat sich jetzt in mich verliebt aber bei
uns haben ausgeprägt psychopathische
eigenschaften exzellenten manipulations
fähigkeiten dann hat er angefangen mich
mit in bordelle zu nehmen damit kann man
hier gut geld verdienen
ich war ja 17 ich war ja noch
minderjährig ich habe einfach dann ein
freier nach dem anderen bedient bis 6
uhr war ich hatte jeden tag schmerzen
und musste dann trotzdem am nächsten
morgen wieder antreten
sie beherrschen dieses spiel mit
zuckerbrot und breite
er hat mit seinen schuhen in die rippen
getreten steh auf du scheißt ihr bis
dato
der einzige mensch der für mich da war
der immer lieb zu mir war ich habe mich
auch total geschehen dass sich das
überhaupt gemacht habe dass ich das
angefangen habe und ich war ihm danach
auch noch höher ich habe ihnen auch
lange zeit danach noch geliebt